the notion of self-consciousness is only
completed in these three moments a the
pure undifferentiated i-in is its first
immediate object b-but this immediacy is
itself an absolute mediation it is only
as a super session of the independent
object in other words it is desire the
satisfaction of desire is it is true the
reflection of self-consciousness into
itself or the certainty that has become
truth see but the truth of this
certainty is really a double reflection
the duplication of self-consciousness
consciousness has for its object one
which of its own self posits its other
nents as a nothingness and in so doing
is independent the differentiated merely
living shape does indeed also supersede
its independence in the process of life
but it ceases with its distinctive
difference to be what it is the object
of self-consciousness however is equally
independent in this negativity of itself
and thus it is for itself a genus a
universal fluid element and the pili
arity of its own separate being it is a
living self-consciousness
we're now arriving at an important
transition point we're reaching the end
of the very first portion of this
section self-consciousness a major part
of Hegel's phenomenology in which some
really key concepts have been developed
some key notions and what Hegel appears
to be doing in paragraph 176 looks a lot
like summary we can actually lay it out
in a fairly systematic almost schematic
form and why can we do that well he says
that at this point the notion the big
lift the the concept you know remember
how important this term is for Hegel
unselfconsciousness has attained a
completed state or if you like it's
reached its fruition it's full ended in
German so a little bit of caution here I
don't think that you want to assume from
Hegel saying that the you know sort of
sweeping conclusion that now we're all
done with self-consciousness we've seen
every bit of its development because
that's clearly not true we have you know
a number of paragraphs yet to go through
you know this much of the work so you
know there's still a lot of work ahead
but some some really important
dimensions of what what
self-consciousness is have been worked
through and we've arrived at a key
conclusion that now we're going to sort
of unpack so let's look at the summary
as Handel puts it down he breaks it down
into three moments the first moment has
to do with the pure undifferentiated i
we saw that in previous paragraphs then
we see you know what self-consciousness
as desire desire in or in orientation to
desire as coming out of but also a
superseding life how that works and how
desire you know aims at satisfaction in
the object then we reach some some
paradoxes of desire that we've just
talked about in previous paragraphs and
then we arrive at this really
interesting feature of the duplication
of self-consciousness
now this is in some respect new at this
point and so we're going to have to
explore well why why is there a
duplication of self-consciousness as
such and not just a duplication of you
know well it wouldn't be a duplication
just this play of self-consciousness and
its objects so let's look at each one in
turn Hegel says in this first moment the
the first object for self-consciousness
is this pure undifferentiated I and you
might say the Hegel we'll wait a second
there when I become aware of myself in
moments of self-consciousness I'm not
becoming aware of myself most of the
time at least empirically as this pure
undifferentiated I content list you know
rather abstract what's going on here and
then Hegel could have two good responses
to that what is that in tracing out this
development of self-consciousness he has
been examining what we might call from a
phenomenological perspective the
essential structures the the you know
metaphysics of the the person of
self-consciousness so you know of course
his analysis you know being a
phenomenological analysis is based to
some degree in experience but it's
supposed to in some way transcend the
the particularities of individual
experience because otherwise it's just
you know secure idiosyncratic stuff that
pertains only to me we've already gone
past that remember with sense certainty
we saw a dialectic of the the you know
the concrete eye and the abstract eye
back then so that's that's one possible
response and Hegel can also say well
look you know if you attend to your
experience closely enough you will in
fact find yourself referring you know
some of what's going on to this this
pure undifferentiated I this is the
power of the negative that he talked
about in in the prophets consciousness
is by its nature a kind of freedom which
means that it you
something rather sorry isn't you know
just what it is it can be other and it
can make other things other by negating
them and that's what this pure
undifferentiated eye does now we saw
that you know that is not going to be a
resting place of course you know we're
not trying to derive some sort of
transcendental category of the eye which
then we would take refuge in a lot of
certain types of transcendental
philosophy and Stephanie Hagel has said
no we need to now go through a process
of you know becoming more and more
concrete through experience so he talks
about desire and you notice I got this
term super session there we know that's
that's okay boom you know this this
transcending and yet incorporating the
essential moments of things so what is
it that desire really wants desire aims
at the Super Session of the at least
being presented at the time independent
object or other and I put object / other
because you know the object is something
that is other than self consciousness
and when we're experiencing the other as
an other as we're gonna with
self-consciousness you know the other
self-consciousness we are taking them as
an object we also make ourselves into
objects in the process as well so that's
what desire wants and desire is seeking
satisfaction the free to go in in German
you know in some ways being being able
to enjoy being able to consume consuming
by negating by nullifying and why is
desire seeking that in the objects than
it is you know you might say what am I
trying to do and in reading this book my
desire is guiding me into the book and I
want to consume what's there I want to
make it my own
I want it no longer to be so independent
of me that it's out there by itself and
want to incorporate it and what I'm
trying to do there Hegel says is to have
both my cake and eat it too
what are we
by that I want to have certainty and I
also want to have truth and we've seen
that there's this interplay between
truth and certainty where oftentimes you
know you can start out with the one that
then you get led away trying to have the
truth and you realize you lost the
certainty in the process or you're
trying to grasp the truth and you start
with that and then you're you know
concerned about how to restore the
certainty these are two important
aspects that are not often well held
together they're they're often you know
splitting apart from each other in the
dialectic okay so that's what desire you
know is is looking for for self
consciousness to be able to bring
together certainty and and truth the way
he puts it it is you know the
satisfaction of desire is the reflection
of self-consciousness into itself or the
certainty that has become true certainty
that has not lost its truth in the
process or truth that has lost certainty
but something that has brought them
together now how is that possible it
takes place through the negating of the
independent object as independent that
leads us to a problem this is where
we're gonna get the duplication of
self-consciousness and I know I could
probably put a couple more exclamation
points here because this is a absolutely
important feature this is going to run
throughout the rest of this entire
section this this you know fact that
we've got to soft consciousnesses or
actually more than - but you know - at
least in the the interplay that we're
looking at so how do we get there well
you know we talked about the paradox of
desire satisfaction right what is the
paradox of desire satisfaction it has to
do with this independence in order to
make the object its own to consume it it
has to in effect bring negation to her
or reduced to nothingness the object yet
if it does that what happens then
it loses the object in the very process
of
consuming and enjoying it so that now it
doesn't have that and like Hegel just
said in the past paragraphs then it's
condemned to this sort of repetition
this reproduction both of the object the
new object and of its desire towards the
object which again can't be satisfied
with this airplane so what's the
possibility you saw this at the end of
the last paragraph well an object that
posits its own nothingness all right
Daphne you know it introduces negation
into itself that you know if we want to
put another more metaphorical terms an
object that it bases itself an object
that humbles itself an object that
offers itself to us so you know this is
this is quite important he says
consciousness has for its object one
which of its own self posits its other
Nisour difference as a nothingness and
in so doing is independent so it becomes
even more paradoxical here right because
this self negation is only possible
because the object actually does possess
an independence so then it brings other
nests it brings difference to itself it
brings nothingness within it
now Hegel doesn't use this term but this
is what is actually going on here the
object is being revealed to us as a
subject whereas better yet a
subjectivity much like our own right
because what kind of things can pull
that off so here's the question why not
just the object as another living thing
why can't that work for some
consciousness you know why can't you
just go retire into nature and you know
experience that and engage with other
living things why do you need another
self consciousness well he tells us here
right the differentiated merely living
shape does indeed also supersede its
independence in the process of life you
know what does that mean that means that
the the thing that's alive
is indeed engaged in this process of
organic growth response to its
environment it becomes other to itself
you know in a way that that mere objects
don't so this is very important but we
saw that life refers to something beyond
mere life it refers to consciousness for
which life is life can only be life for
something that is not just life so he
says it doesn't supersede its
independence in the process of life but
it ceases with its distinctive
difference to be what it is so there's a
lack of continuity there's a restricted
miss to the living thing we might you
know here instead of saying thing say
the living plant the living animal right
better animal than plant but we cannot
find the sort of satisfaction that we're
looking for in those because they don't
have the kind of subjectivity that a
human being does I don't want to get
them to any great debates about whether
octopi have subjectivity or dolphins or
anything like that you know Hegel did
not know as much about animal behavior
as we did he was also you know
inheriting from the ancients a notion
that you know being the rational animal
were fundamentally distinct from the
others so perhaps there's there's you
know possibilities for something more to
be included in there well let's just go
with what he actually says the object
for forsook self certainty for this this
you know desire that we have must be he
says an other living consciousness and I
put your subconsciousness in parentheses
because that sort of goes without saying
what we're actually desiring is an
object that can negate itself and do so
in time concretely in relation to us in
the way that we ourselves can and now
think about this too we can also know it
to be doing that because
it is like us so what is it that we're
actually looking for we're looking for
another self-consciousness he says the
object of self-consciousness is equally
independent in this negativity of itself
right it can negate the way that we can
thus it is for itself a genus the entire
process that we have just sort of
spelled out for ourselves as you know
traveling along this this developing
consciousness that developing
self-consciousness is also going out
over there in that self-consciousness
and over there and that
self-consciousness and with the one that
we want to relate ourselves to the one
in which we want to find our
consummation and our satisfaction of
desire so it says it is for itself a
genus it is for itself the same kind of
genus that we ourselves are at the same
time being part of the same you know
genus in terms of being human beings
each one we're going to see this play
itself not very much in the later
sections is also like its own genus or
species or type onto itself we have to
explore it nor in order to find out what
it is we can make snap judgments about
the other while you're just one of those
kind of people scratch the surface and
in most cases we find out that's not
really the case there's this interior
tea
that goes beyond one of the other living
things have to offer so this is what's
going on has the entire you know concept
the entire because of self-consciousness
been exhausted no but now we actually
have a lot to work with
a self-consciousness exists for a
self-consciousness only so is it in fact
self-consciousness for only in this way
does the unity of itself in its other
nets become explicit for it the I which
is the object of its notion is in fact
not object the object of desire however
is only independent for it is the
universal indestructible substance the
fluence self identical essence a
self-consciousness in being an object is
just as much I as object with this we
already have before us the notion of
spirit what still lies ahead for
consciousness is the experience of what
spirit is this absolute substance which
is the unity of the different
independent self consciousness is which
in their opposition enjoy perfect
freedom and independence I that is we
and we that is high it is in self
consciousness in the notion of spirit
the consciousness first finds its
turning point where it leaves behind it
the colorful show of the sensuous here
and now and the night like void of the
supersensible beyond and steps out into
the spiritual daylight of the present
we're now at the crux the ending of this
portion of the the self consciousness
section where our transition is going to
be made to the other parts which are
even more complex there's a lot more
going on there and then eventually to
two further sections and Hegel thinks
that we've made a really significant
advance part of that is you might say
latent in what are you talking about at
the very start of the paragraph in in
177 which is going to be that you know
played out in this diagram that I've got
here but part of it is also what we're
seeing at the very end of this this
passage and so I want to begin with that
and talk a little bit about its
implications so he says it is in
self-consciousness in the notion of
spirit that consciousness first finds
its turning point where it leaves behind
the colorful show of the sensuous here
and now and the night-light void of the
supersensible beyond and steps out into
the spiritual daylight of the present so
what we're talking about here is not not
leaving behind as in you know totally
disregarding but rather this process of
out of Haven of sublation of bringing
along with us but getting past and
showing how this you know leads to
something greater
you know something new is coming out of
the scene that we have to now assimilate
and so you know the the possibility
being captivated with the you know the
empirical world that were confronted
with the world that we think is the
world of experience but which is only a
world of you know sensuous experience
and then the supersensible beyond you
know this is what the force laws the the
you know the the inverted world all that
sort of stuff and you know the play of
consciousness now we're stepping out as
he says into the daylight of
self-consciousness which is going to
lead us ultimately to spirit which is
what this whole thing is about the
phenomenology of spirit right so we're
really making some progress now he
begins by saying self-consciousness is
the book has
this but it might be a better way to put
it yes does you know you could translate
it either way self-consciousness is for
another self-consciousness you don't get
self-consciousness concretely by itself
you might say that the very metaphysical
prerequisite of having one
self-consciousness is that there be more
than one well this is really interesting
consciousness by itself doesn't
necessarily imply this
self-consciousness which we would think
what could be just you know one unity
doesn't exist as self-consciousness
without other self-consciousness without
an interplay between them yeah you know
this is this is an idea that's been
played out an awful lot by some Hegel
commentators and scholars you know most
notably by koja who really begins his
study of Hegel by thinking this this
particular term oh I'm not going to
dwell on that too much although than to
say that in this I think that that coach
Adam is on the right track that when we
think about determinate human beings we
can abstract away you know imaginatively
from the relations with others or we
could look at it in a way that seems to
be you know metaphysical but is really
you know treating individual human
beings as if they're subjects or
substances when the very nature of human
being part of what makes us what we are
is that we are relational creatures we
are relational with each other so I
cannot have my entire being in myself
and then just relate myself to another
being that's perfectly you know opaque
and finished by itself rather we are
always in in process and we are always
in messy relations with others here the
relations aren't quite so messy because
we're trying to keep it simple but if
you think about the way it is for us and
in real life it is quite messy so he
goes on he says only in this way does
the unity of itself in its other nests
become explicit for it
only by relating ourselves to another
self-consciousness can we be fully aware
of the unity that we are because that's
not a unity of just like a closed-off
you know exactly what it is throughout
all of its tissues sort of thing our
unity is a unity in connection with
other unities that have the same
capacity so he says the unity of itself
in its other nacelle feathering if we
weren't we couldn't have followed along
with the entire thing that Hegel's been
doing here because the very dialectical
logic that he's been following out where
even you know you know things that don't
have consciousness but are only for
consciousness you have all tyranny they
have a capacity to self other you know
there's this repulsion of the self same
from the self same the attraction of the
unlike to unlike all this sort of stuff
were able to understand because we are
that kind of creature but we can only
become aware of that in relation to
another self consciousness or fully
aware of that we can only work it out so
he says the I which is the object of its
notion is is in fact not object the
object of desire however is only
independent for it is the universal
indestructible substance the fluid self
identical essence so let's show you how
I'm trying to lay this out for you in a
schematic form right so the I which is
the object of its notion is in fact not
object right it doesn't remain merely
objective that's part of what it means
to be an i to have that capacity for
negation that capacity of freedom that
distancing itself from from concrete
empirical existence which seems to like
fix it to to the points from which it
cannot deviate so that these are both
aspects of the self the self the self
consciousness makes itself an arm's
for itself we've seen this play itself
up at the same time it is also that
which is able to stand back and say aye
it's both of these at once so it's both
sides of the knot the equation that both
sides of both moments of the the
dialectic they're the same thing is
going out here with the other
self-consciousness and you know when
we're talking about desire desire is is
connecting us or coming out of this
fluid self identical essence which is
what which is life what we've been
person out and looking at in the last
paragraph so he says a
self-consciousness in being an object is
just as much I as object when we make
ourselves into objects or when we see
ourselves as the objects for another
right when the the other self is looking
at us as an object and saying something
like hey you that hey you includes both
sort of a date acress it's sort of like
in putting the the pointer out and
treating somebody in many respects as an
object as you could say look at that
tree over there right at the same time
it's being addressed to another person
in language at least in in most
languages I don't know if this holds for
every language we have the second person
right you thou thee you know we we
differentiate between sometimes singular
and plural there's in Greek there's
actually dual and other things as well
what's going on there something is being
treated as both object and as I at the
same time when I'm trying to you know
think about myself as I might be doing
as I'm thinking about this board and the
diagram there where do I fit in there I
am treating myself both as object and as
as this I as a subject
so that's something really central to
the to us face the other a little bit
lemme nasus to be so angry okay so he
says with this we have already before us
the notion of spirit so this is a key
idea right there's this interplay going
on here
self is related to other this is the
other to this self at the same time this
self over here which is the only kind of
other and should probably do this all
right if if this other isn't a self it
can't satisfy my desire it can't give me
my own self-consciousness I also realize
that within myself there's other thing
as well and it's uttering for the other
people this is how complicated this is
getting there's a lot of reflection
going on here so I'm getting very
excited about this as well but that's
because this is really central stuff
this is a very very important paragraph
now desire is one of the key things that
is connecting all of this together as we
saw my own desire is not entirely my own
it is partly already over there being
conditioned by the other that means the
same thing about the others desire I
exist as a self consciousness because
I'm related to a self consciousness
which also feels desire towards me in
the same way so we leave behind the
realm of just life which is still a
basis is still there is still involved
it's just being sublated and we're
seeing how we get through this play of
desire to what Hegel is calling the
notion of spirits spirits is what the
whole book is about as I mentioned
before so he says was a beautiful
passage here what still lies ahead for
consciousness is the experience of what
spirit is
that's what the rest of this book is the
experience of what spirit is so he says
this absolute substance which is the
unity of the different independent self
consciousnesses which in their
opposition these are close to each other
they can be related to each other in a
lot of ways enjoy perfect freedom and
independence sounds very utopian doesn't
it that's because we're not going to get
to this position of absolute freedom and
independence and to use another term
that he's going to bring in very soon
recognition between the different
self-consciousness is in spirit we're
not going to get there right away
human human kind he hasn't actually
gotten there all the way even in Hegel's
own time he thinks that he has figured
out the blueprint for this but it has to
be put into effect within existing
societies which have to be transformed
in the process now he says what what I
think is you know most wonderful about
this he calls this AI that is we and we
that is I so that is and we set this
point in the game how we can
characterize what's going on with spirit
I that is we and we that is AI how do we
bring together the the self
consciousness is to create a we it's
very easy and this is you know something
that happens all the time when people
are pushy to you know have one person
using we terminology all the time and
they don't just mean the Royal we like
you know we shall have a grilled cheese
sandwich and I mean I will have a
grilled cheese sandwich I mean you know
we're gonna do all this this stuff
together I just happen to be the one who
can you know orchestrate it and who
knows what each person ought to do as a
member of the team which by the way I'll
run and I'll have the handouts for you
when when you come to the meeting that's
that's not what Hegel's talking about
here but we will often have to
transition through that because we have
a tendency to subsume the the we into
our own eye or to take on somebody
else's eye as what's you know going to
give us
we that we can be involved in these are
two things that has to be overcome and
we're going to see him talking about how
this is done I don't want to end on on
that note I want to end on sort of
reaffirming what we we began with and
what we end with in this passage this is
opening up for us a new way of looking
at things all the previous consciousness
material is still there we've brought it
along with us we've used parts of it
that were were particularly helpful at
certain points some of its going to
re-emerge later on but now we are taking
a fundamentally different perspective
not so that we can nullify everything
but so that we can broaden the the
viewpoint that we have and see how these
self consciousnesses actually relate to
each other
you